[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Flutter is
a portable UI tool
kit for building beautiful
native applications
for mobile, web, and desktop
from a single codebase.
Here at Google, we've been busy
with Flutter over the last year
and want to show you what
we've been working on.
We shipped several updates,
including our 1.0 Stable
Release, and added features
and enhancements many of you
have asked for.
For example, we added support
for integrating Flutter
into existing
Android or iOS apps,
making it easier to get
started with Flutter,
even if you already have
an app in the store.
Also, we have put a lot of
investment into our add-ins
for Visual Studio Code
and Android Studio
and created a new suite
of web-based tooling
for debugging and inspecting
Flutter applications.
We've continued to invest in iOS
with an extensive and growing
library of widgets and classes
that make it easier than ever
to build pixel-perfect iOS apps.
Beyond the core
framework itself,
we have been building out
the supporting ecosystem,
publishing new packages
for Google Maps,
Firebase ML Vision, in-app
purchases, and WebViews.
Dart is the programming
language for Flutter
because it is optimized
for client development.
With hot reload
powered by the Dart-vm,
developers can iteratively
make changes and instantly see
results in their app.
Also, Dart compiles
to native machine
code for mobile and desktop, as
well as JavaScript for the web.
We've continued
to invest in ways
to make Dart a great language
for Flutter development.
For example, as
part of Flutter 1.5,
we added new language
features, including
support for conditional UI.
We have also focused
on making compiled code
even faster, leading
to a 15% performance
increase in many cases.
Now that Flutter has shipped
several releases for mobile,
we're setting our sights
wider to other devices
and application types, including
the web, Chromebooks, Windows,
Mac, and embedded form factors.
Flutter is an open
source product,
so the community
is a major source
of feedback, documentation,
and code contributions.
We've had major
community contributions
towards areas such as
desktop support and state
management, which makes
Flutter better for everyone.
This past year,
we've seen developers
all over the world
creating apps with Flutter
that are being used by
hundreds of millions of users.
And LinkedIn data says Flutter
is the fastest growing skill
among software engineers.
Within Google, we
are using Flutter
in a wide variety of
products, from Google Ads
to smart displays like
the Google Home Hub.
Now is the perfect time
to start developing
your apps with Flutter.
Try it out at flutter.dev,
where you will also
find codelabs, documentation,
and a guide to getting started.
We can't wait to
see what you build.